Our next guest is a very,
very dear friend of the show and guru
of green living and sustainability.
He's the editor in chief of "Naturally, Danny Seo".
Danny, I love you.
It's Danny Seo, everybody!
(audience cheers)
(adience claps)
Hi everyone!
I love it!
This show has changed my life.
Really?
I love this show.
For me it's New York City, 9:00 AM.
I watch the whole hour every morning with a cup of coffee.
Oh dear.
And something I think
you all could watch with a cup of coffee
also is with this recipe that we're gonna make together too.
Let's do it, Danny!
I'm in your passenger seat, you're the driver.
(audience claps)
It is
completely gluten-free, it's plant-based.
This is a broccoli creamy polenta spoon bread.
It's comforting, but again, gluten-free, plant-based,
and you can make it all in the blender, which is so amazing.
So we're gonna put in a dairy free milk,
so this is coconut milk, but you can do almond milk,
you could do whatever you want,
but the coconut milk has that extra fat in it,
which is really nice.
It does.
And then these are
our dry ingredients; we've got nutritional yeast,
that's the cheesiness, oat flour, garlic powder,
baking powder, salt.
It's all very just simple things you can find
and we're just gonna carefully put this all
in the blender guys.
So it's not messy.
So we'll take this beautiful blender
and I'm just gonna turn it on
and then we're gonna liquefy it.
(blender beeps)
(blenders whir)
Now, Danny, what consistency should it be?
Should it be truly liquified and emulsified?
Pancake batter consistency.
This is perfect.
This is absolutely perfect.
So we're gonna leave it in our blender for now,
and we're gonna do one more thing, Drew.
Do you like miso paste?
I love miso!
Is this a white or a red?
This is a white.
It doesn't matter what you have.
You can find this in the refrigerated section
at your supermarket.
A little bit of miso paste
and in the bowl we have grated sweet potato.
And what we're gonna do is massage-
I thought this was carrot.
Sweet potato.
Mm!
Sweet potato for fiber and flavor,
and we're gonna mix it together.
What's happening is that the natural saltiness of the miso,
it's breaking down the toughness of the sweet potato.
So you're massaging it in to make it soft and tender
so that you still have those pieces of sweet potato
in the spoon bread, but it's not gonna be tough.
It's gonna bake all the way through.
So we're gonna pour our liquid right into the bowl,
just like this, combine all of our ingredients together
and guys, that's it!
Can you believe that?
It's so easy to make and what you do
is in a large cast iron pan like this,
you wanna grease it with a high heat oil.
So avocado oil, coconut oil.
I love avocado oil.
Okay, so in your cast, iron pan, guys,
that's been greased,
all you do is pour it all the way in.
And if you notice,
I said, this is broccoli, so we're missing the broccoli.
We're gonna scrape it all in.
I wanna get it all into our cast iron pan.
I'm the biggest broccoli fan.
It's a super food.
I grew up vegetarian.
My mom and I lived in California in the 1970s and
we were like the total cliche and
that kinda hippie era stuff.
Actually, we were so not, there were so many odd-
(audience laughs)
(laughing) You don't wanna mix it (laughs).
Oops.
It's gonna be delicious, but you want the broccoli
to cook and be floating on top.
And we're just gonna put the pretty broccoli on top.
Okay.
In a really nice pattern.
(audience claps)
Like that, you see that?
Yeah, I'm on it.
Oh thank you, Danny!
Oh and they're frozen?
They're frozen on purpose,
so this is something where you don't need fresh broccoli.
Frozen broccoli is actually just as fresh.
All the nutrients are locked in and what it does,
it helps it keep its shape and it's...
Beautiful.
I mean, that's what women
come off like on a cooking demo.
Like, I'm just casual and I'm placing my broccoli.
I only know like Lucille Ball style.
I'm like, "Oh my god, oh my god, ah!"
And I love to cook!
Listen, it's still gonna be delicious,
but this is also a way of making it just sort of
like a beautiful one dish meal.
It goes into the oven at 375 degrees
for about 50 minutes to an hour
50 minutes.
until it's crispy
coming across from the edges,
but you want it to be not dry.
It's gonna be a spoon bread
so it's a little bit moist and wet and it's perfect
whenever you just want a food that hugs you.
Can I have a bite?
Yes, oh my gosh, it's right here guys.
And it's so good with a little dollop of yogurt,
serve it warm.
I'm salivating.
Oh my god!
Isn't it good?
Savory.
It's very moist.
Cheesy.
Yeah, and it's in the winter issue of my magazine.
You can get the recipe for this or just go
to TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com.
So Drew, I have a question for you
about a cast iron pan.
One of the things that we love a cast iron,
but we don't like the heat that it holds, which is great,
but also it can scorch your countertop,
and also it can be hard to hold,
so I wanna show you a really great DIY.
Okay, I'm in, I learn so much from you, Danny.
So we're gonna learn a DIY, how to make-
(Danny laughs)
We're gonna make something to protect your hands,
but also to protect your countertops too.
That's a little sneak peak.
Okay, well I think we're gonna go
to a quick commercial break
and then we're gonna learn this amazing hack and tip
from Danny because it doesn't stop at food.
It's everything, this is a whole lifestyle that he presents.
That's why he's changed my life.
(upbeat music)